[Music]
thanks for joining us here at noon i'm
heather mills let's jump right into some
breaking news an explosion at a
commercial facility in boulder city
multiple injuries police fire hazmat
crews are all on the scene this happened
just before 10 this morning on spring
canyon road near the 95 and that is
where we find our victoria saha with the
latest on what happened victoria
heather this is as close as we can get
to the scene you can see behind me the
line of ambulance and ems trucks that
responded to this explosion it happened
just before 10 at amarok palmere
concrete police say the building was
evacuated right away initially we heard
that one person had minor injuries but
now we're just learning that seven
employees were hospitalized when we
arrived we were told to stand back
because this is an active scene hazmat
crews are working to clean up the
chemicals it's still unclear how long
the evacuation will last we haven't been
able to get a clear picture of the
damage the explosion caused reporting
live in boulder city victoria saha live
local now okay we'll stay on top